the guys that are out there to talk
giving all these advice they're not even
like marriage they don't even get
girlfriends but somehow they're [__]
gurus and [__] it's hilarious
the guys that are in stable loving
relationships are out here and they're
like called Simpsons you know what
though like the key to a secret like a
good marriage is like being able to say
things under your breath like real
quietly
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are currently off the
Record
today we have Jesse mama oh hello
um I think you are a good person to help
settle this thing that's been going
around online that I do not appreciate
personally okay
um why is it that Filipino guys have
such a bad reputation for being toxic to
date are they real what are you dating a
Filipino man right now no but I have a
lot of dancers or Filipinos are they are
they quite toxic Filipino dancer what is
the deal because that's like everywhere
when you have these girls doing tier
lists of like who's the most toxic it's
always the number ones or the Viet guy
but it's usually filming can you can you
educate me because I've never heard of
this before yeah me neither I actually
don't know the reasons though but what
makes you say they are toxic I think
just like from anecdotally my
relationships yeah like what happened I
speak from your experience
um because a lot of other girls do agree
because I've been seeing that going
around yeah it's a thing just do what we
do and like take something anecdotal and
just pretend like everyone does it yeah
oh what have you observed from like
friends that dated that you've like seen
yeah like what's the class on
Philippines the hot guys also also is it
a misconception I'll take that as an
answer too is it true what they tell us
why Ryan's toxic come on Ryan why are
you toxic I think Filipino guys are are
a lot of them are naturally charismatic
that's a generalized compliment okay
yeah I feel like Filipinos are the RICO
suavees of Asians yeah yeah it's a
Spanish blood Dante Bosco has the swap
oh God Dante come on what's the next
kid's called Riz yeah the curves no so
they're charismatic and that does that
and they know it I never know they also
have Latin infidelities oh
Latin infidelity like telenovela style
yeah they can resist the fashion for
everybody can you confirm with it it's
like Puss in Boots he just like the
pools it's like Pepe Le Pew yeah so
that's the main issue you think is that
they just get to uh passionate yeah
actually it's like two extremes like I
know a lot of Filipino men who are very
committed and like have like long long
term and those are usually the nurses
huh the military or the military
Filipinos yeah but that's anecdotal
dancer is that one of the dancer thing
or is that a Filipino thing
oh maybe it's the intersection of both
oh that's two bads there so you got the
really extremes
is your anecdotal all dancers mostly
okay so that doesn't count huh my sample
size is just like different most toxic
yeah but then I feel like all Filipinos
know how to dance and sing and they're
in they're in the medical field that's
how I feel too so you're pretty much
dating the average Filipino man right
yeah yeah yeah if they're break dancing
or popping
so my father-in-law 's Filipino man and
he has been described as having toxic
traits what are these toxic traits
drinking and driving
come on man that's literally there's
toxicity in his blood yes
um yeah a lot of yelling apparently when
when uh when they were growing up
um that's standard but that's also like
so all of us growing up too yeah that
might be a generational thing does he
have a gambling addiction or did he ever
have one I don't think so because I
didn't know that that was a big thing
until I got older he's a he's a
Filipinos gamble yeah because like
Seventh-Day Adventists I got we didn't
see a lot of gambling but then when I
got older and I had friends from outside
school a lot of their dads had issues
with drinking and gambling I feel like
if you're an Asian from a religious cult
you kind of don't fit The Stereotype
because you're an outcast of your own
group a little bit yeah it's true yeah
well he's also a tax guy so I think he
just was always more built to be
responsible with money oh okay that
makes sense yeah but what's the what
makes it because I feel like
generationally
they were all toxic so what makes
Filipino like extra the highest rate the
highest of all Asians I don't even know
that's the thing I don't know I see it
all the time that a lot of girls have
that opinion but
it's been going around though on Tick
Tock I don't know but they don't explain
it it's just a guy that goes up and then
they rank they'll be like all right out
of all the Asians which one is the most
toxic because not gonna lie it's
Filipino I think I think Filipino dudes
maybe just I don't know if it's
generational but they do have a high
rate of like fuckboyism I think a lot of
them so maybe at some point they like
hurt somebody or they they weren't into
them that way and then they kind of like
cold shoulder it yeah I could think of a
couple of Filipino friends that I'm like
oh yeah they're little [__] boys what
race is Anthony Lee
he's Filipino adjacent yeah because he
married a Filipino wait Anthony's Viet
Chinese right oh no he's Viet that's why
he's a he's a toxic [__] boy the second
in line those girls would always say is
Viet so okay like I thought it was Viet
guys in my tier list of my friends I
would have put yeah guys as the number
one toxic from my observation I didn't
know that most girls thought it was
Filipinos
um you know what made me sad Japanese
didn't even make it on the list that
made you sad that you're not toxic yeah
that means they're not [__]
[__] stupid they're not [__] yeah
what was what was the list nobody thinks
we [__]
it was like
yeah a lot of girls brought up Filipinos
they brought up in Korean Korean they
brought up they said yeah Koreans they
drama whatever whatever and then I'm
like they never said Japanese we need
flaws come on dude the reason why that's
why the reason why you're not toxic is
no one's dating your ass yeah stop
[__] being an apprentice sushi chef
and [__] working all day in your in
your personal tearless Jesse is
filipino's number one time what's number
two agrees
um
just men
yeah I think like you're not you're not
stereotypical enough what do guys do
that are so toxic yeah I don't even know
what that means it might be more racist
please you've been described as toxic
many times are you toxic
what do you guys think is toxic that's
the thing I don't even subjective right
so yeah what do you think is like what
are some toxic traits that you feel like
when you're dating some dude toxicity to
me is when you leave the girl in worse
shape than she was prior to meeting you
I that's how I Define toxicity that's a
good oh dude I've never been toxic like
is credit carding random women at the
store toxic no that's just fun that's
just a fun chill dude yeah that's just
not it that's just somebody I want to
get bearded that's just AFV yeah yeah
not if you make the cha-ching noise if
you make a change yeah then it's playful
and fun or if it's like oh sorry it
didn't read and then you're gonna do it
again Batman you got your chain but if
you if you just do it silently creepy
bro
okay in that case the way I defined it
there are a lot of situations where I
think Filipino guys do that I do like
that explanation you said where you left
the or the girl leave because you're
toxifying the person a worse person than
when you
uh met them and I would say uh when I
was a junior in high school I was toxic
yeah would you do [__] oh I had a chick
that was like she was like um doing
really good in school yeah and then and
then she ended up like waking up at
random people's houses and then like she
stopped being the debate team anymore
and like
yeah I was like a really bad influence
why
you stopped her from being disagreeable
you're a fun time dude I think that was
really fun though yeah but is that toxic
is that funny I think or fun can also be
toxic no I think it's like well I think
I did worse [__] where like if I was
breaking up with someone I wanted to
have the upper hand so I wanted them to
be sadder than I was at the end of it oh
Jesus Filipino toxic I've done that and
I think that is a Filipino I never did
that that's [__] up it's [__] up
yeah your thing was you were just a bad
influence I think I was bad as best
toxic but this is like a more like
direct well I mean if it depends because
like what if you influenced her in that
way but then she ended up being like a
really cool skater or something like
that's kind of I think I took her away
from her dreams okay
that's not good that's heavy yeah
because you go to like just there's
Middle School no no uh junior year in
high school she's trying to go to USC
and then we ended up like going to a
rave in Arizona
and then you know what I think it is I
think Filipino guys generally have a
coping mechanism that is dependent on
the other person feeling worse than they
do oh so that's what makes it toxic
because you gotta like
okay yeah I think that's how they feel
you want to hurt me I'm going to hurt
you I think that's how they feel good
about their decisions is that they want
they need someone else to like the other
person to suffer a little bit so they're
like oh I came out okay and then you can
move forward without guilt they or me
no I did it for many years so I get it
but like when um I think when girls are
talking about Filipino guys being toxic
that's probably gotta be in there
somewhere yeah because I think they
leave a wreckage behind I've actually
never been cheated on but it's more of
like the lying and the manipulation oh
oh that's toxic to me is it a flex to be
like I've never been cheated on yeah
I could see it I could see a little bit
good get it honey get it girl yeah get
it work girl I've probably been cheated
on but I never knew that's a nice Flex
too yeah that's nice that's like kind of
a cooler flag
yeah because it's a mystery it's a
mystery who knows I don't know I might
have been cheated on yep Schrodinger's
cheating yeah it is don't open the box
there is a I think like especially when
I met other families that were not
non-religious not that this is like
better but like they uh they did have
dads that were like Filipino salsa dads
oh dude those guys and I didn't know
that was a stereotype like Filipino
salsa dads like are pretty they cheat
the way they move their hips yeah come
on yeah they're crushing it they'd be
doing like little lessons with like
different women and then I had a friend
his dad's a personal trainer and he told
me that his dad probably [__] every
single one of his clients wow and his
dad gave him steroids when he was like
16 too that's pretty tight whoa I mean
he sounds like damn Bilzerian in the
future damn
geez
any other guy any any redeeming
qualities of Filipino guys
oh I think they're uh no let's end the
video how can we save them
how can we say I think they're doing
just fine
I think they're killing I've always
liked Filipino guys because I feel like
they're
optimistic and happy all the time
they're fun hangs dude yeah Filipino
dudes are funny I think that's the charm
that gets the girls yeah because when
you're like East Asian there's no sex
really yeah like maybe perversion but
there's really no passion and like the
stereotypes different yeah so then I'm
like even I want a Filipino guy yeah
they're like more free yeah and in the
East Asians like Chinese Japanese like
Koreans are more they're coming out more
romantic they're like the more emotional
one out of the three but then like dude
like
typically man there's like no it's
different would you ever race Anthony
Lee is that's probably my least favorite
one
that's true we're just talking about
favorite races now
what if what is a common toxic trait
that men have in relationships that we
don't know about yeah tell us yeah
because you said number two is all bad
number one is the Filipino and the
number two is oh man no all men yeah all
others yeah what is something what's
toxic stuff because you know what I
think too is that sometimes a lot of
people have trauma and the toxic [__]
that they do is impulsive and not
intentional so I'm like what is a common
thing that you've seen like in dating
that that does keep coming up literally
this is like it's it's not even juicy
it's Ben's inability to self-regulate
their own emotions and traumas and
that's why it comes up and that's why
like because communication is key you
can work through really anything you can
make mistakes and you can work through
it but usually men like ball up and they
don't want to consider another
perspective they don't want to be open
and that's a lot of like past stuff
being like they're hanging on to yeah a
lot of chicks always complain like most
relationships it's always the girl
complaining about their dude not
communicating yes yeah
I've had that problem with every single
guy and then the more I get to know them
and actually like love and have empathy
for them I'm like Oh no you're hurt
um yeah
yeah how do you address it yeah stop
hiding yourself you dumbass I'm kidding
stop being a [__] about it no I I have
um an issue too because I get angry I'm
Korean you know so they make them
tighten up like yeah they're they're
defensive now yeah like like we're as
much as I want to help I'm also like
aggressive you know
um my boyfriend's Colombian he said that
he thinks that Korean women are the
Latinas of Asia you know we're like
expressive and dramatic and angry and so
but that's uh that's bad too because
that does obviously make like fire with
fire yeah yeah
if I could like if I had the
self-control and the money and the time
I think my passion project in life would
be actually to like lead men's retreats
that'll be cool and give like love and
listening to people and and I think
because like I'm like
God like women have it so hard and
that's what I focus on a lot of the time
but women have it hard because of men
but men have it hard because of men
interesting in relationships and
everything works that's true I have work
trauma relationship trauma and it's men
I think that's what I always thought was
weird where um women would look at men
as one cohesive monolithic group but
guys are against guys competing against
guys protecting others from guys you
know but what about the guys that are
protecting the world from you know the
yeah it's just [__] why is it isn't
[__] pretty tough on each other too
I feel like I feel like that's true too
yeah yeah my my
um perspective I mean I I think a lot of
guys have that experience but looking
back my
um assessment of what happened to me was
that like I didn't grow up understanding
how to identify those things so when I
was told why are you holding back I
didn't even know I was holding back so
then it felt more like an accusation of
like why are you not doing something
that you know you can do so then holding
back what so for example right like
let's say um
I can't even identify what's happening
to me right now but I'm being pressured
to express myself when I can't even put
it into words which just pissed me off
yeah you haven't processed what's going
on it's like yeah yeah it's like maybe
some people are hiding how they truly
feel but in my case I can't even
register and I don't even have that
emotional IQ to know that this is how
I'm feeling this is how I'm processing
like I don't even have those tools so
then I just get blamed for not
expressing the things that I'm unaware
about so then it becomes like this thing
where it's like I'm being accused of
holding back when I'm not holding back I
do want to express I do want to have
this discussion I'm just not even there
yet so a retreat like that can help
people get to that point where now they
can go oh I am angry yeah and the real
reason why I'm angry is not because you
made me angry is because oh I have a
trigger for whatever past thing but
that's so much self-awareness and but I
feel like
now there's more guys talking about this
[__] right but in the past like if you
don't practice that it's like it's like
weight training or anything or any skill
set you have to practice that and if if
you can't even for it's like being an
alcoholic right you can't you can't
admit to your addiction or you can't
admit and see yourself yeah you can't
even you're not even at that stage so a
lot of guys are out there in
relationships being told because a woman
could probably clearly see what's going
on and you're like why you you know why
are you suppressing this part of you and
then they're like what the [__] are you
talking about I'm not suppressing [__]
I'm lashing out yeah and then it causes
this because then it's like the reflex
right some chicks though think they're
[__] body language experts
then I'm like [__] there's nothing
wrong there's that too there's that too
where you're just because men do be
blanking like like men do just like are
not thinking about we're just standing I
literally I'm starting with the
breathing okay I'm actually just taking
some time breathing no and then there's
some type of projection going on where
it's like what are you thinking about
what are you doing and it's like no
those those are your insecurities I'm
breathing today
I'm just breathe I'm not then you have
to make up something that you probably
thought you were thinking about the
discussion yeah I was thinking about
[__] butterflies okay do you guys
relate to that yeah for sure all guys do
I think women a lot of women do give
dudes more credit
than they deserve because I dudes are
really simple minded and then I think
because women are such like internal
multitaskers and they can think about
all kinds of things and like all kinds
of perspectives they're like oh he must
be doing this because of this but the
dudes literally just breathing
inside of a dude's brain is like
I was having a conversation with my wife
and I don't know if you know this but
I'm a mouth reader just by trade by
trade okay and then she was she we're
having a conversation about something
serious and I wasn't we the conversation
ended and I've been trying to breathe
out my nose more often right so I just
go
are you upset or something and I was
like I was like oh no no I was just
trying to breathe out my nose but she
didn't believe it for a little bit
exactly and I had to keep convincing her
I was like no no like
I'm trying to breathe out my nose man
come on you know I'm a mouth breather
baby you know me I'm a mouth breather
I'm on my computer
like this
what's what's happening I feel like
you're mad at me when you do that he's
like babe everything okay I'm like I
think I just figured out how to fit Jiu
Jitsu into my schedule because I was
just on yup looking at what's open in
the morning that's another thing too
she thought it was like some crazy [__]
but I was like I think I settled it
there's these three places I'm gonna DM
I'm gonna see what's up
so you finally have a 6 a.m class that
fits my schedule but she knows me now
after 15 years she knows I'm not
bullshitting yeah but a lot of I think a
lot of times and when it's early on it's
like it cannot be that [__] simple
what what
and then it blows up because like then
you put the [__] in the room together
and then they all start talking about
how we were staring at the wall yeah and
like it must mean this other thing and
then they're all like tag team in that
[__] point and then they come back
with a different story like a whole
novel of what you were doing and I'm
like oh I just stare at the [__]
world you're like well not as smart as
you think I am
yeah it's either I'm staring at the wall
I'm having a dinosaur battle play in my
head or I was thinking I'm thinking
about who I'm gonna eat tomorrow yeah
it's 100 I'm done
I think a Stegosaurus could beat a T-Rex
what if a brontosaurus had to defend
itself against a meat eater yeah
and he just thinking man I don't know it
kind of brontosaurus really [__] up a
raptor cause like brontosaurus just eat
grass all day it has a long neck right
but then the Raptors are much smaller
much worse
so it's not always
what what women think probably most of
the time not but I do agree though that
would be really good a retreat where a
guy can start processing with no
judgment how to identify certain things
and then be able to communicate it in a
relationship because I think like guys
can communicate
girls do this too where it's like in a
few words because you just know so much
but I think in a relationship setting it
does help to be able to communicate more
thoroughly and the thought process
behind it because I think females just
think so differently from us that in
order to package that message correctly
it has to be in depth I can't say though
being with a female has helped me
communicate better with dudes too I
think so just because like it's opened
up my brain to so many other
perspectives and a way of communicating
and like like what's the best form like
sometimes like it's not always a hammer
always a screwdriver you know it's like
there's like different ways of applying
stuff and there's ways of like maybe I
don't even need to use words maybe if I
go like this with Nick Nick knows that I
love him you know and then that's true
yeah being a father too like and it's
like there's so many ways yeah well also
my brain like like [__] can just do
layers of thinking right
and I can only do like one at a time
right I got like one little sir one
little one thing at a time they're like
it is yeah
but these [__] doing like [__] all
this twisting thinking about things like
she could think about many things at one
time and I don't even know how to I'm
trying to think about lunch you know
that's what I'm thinking about it's so
great that all four of these guys have
highly successful marriages yeah I
wouldn't say highly successful I don't
know I uh yeah I would say highly
successful anyone that says that they're
[__] alive everyone's been in a
relationship here over a decade yeah way
over a decade it's funny because the
guys that are out there uh talk giving
all these advice they're not even like
marriage they don't even get girlfriends
but somehow they're [__] gurus and
[__] it's hilarious
the guys that are in stable loving
relationships are out here and they're
like called simps and [__] you know what
though like the keto secret like a good
marriage is like being able to say
things under your breath like real
quietly
foreign